c49b5 is on the board ladies and gentlemen
jordan is getting closer and closer to a win
jordan is just playing marvelous chess he's
lost zero games so he's not taking risk
jordan fun forest with impressive amazing
performance amazing games wins the last
round we are in for a tie breaks people we have
tie break between two dutchmen
aneesh giri and jordan fun for race
oh my we have the winner of the tournament that it
is jordan fanfares winning the dramatic armageddon
basically it comes down to a lot of luck so i
don't know he played the better chess maybe i
played the faster chess in the end and full credit
to him he played a really good tournament and he
really deserved to win it i mean he was could
have won both of his last games too i think
but yeah this is just how it goes and how do
you feel yeah just on top of the road i think
so a lot of feelings um but going through
my head but i think it still has to you
know still in a bit come hit me you know and
i think that comes when all the interviews and
and stuff is done and when i'm like at night
in my bed trying to sleep something like this